paren de matarnos es el lema con el que
los manifestantes marcharon hasta las
instalaciones de la policía civil de río
de janeiro en protesta por las víctimas
del jueves tras una operación policial
en una favela la policía y las
autoridades del país aseguran que todos
eran bandidos pero los habitantes de la
favela y activistas lo niegan para ellos
esta es una nueva masacre contra la
población afro brasileña
todos los días todas las operaciones que
se realizan dentro de la favela siempre
tienen una persona inocente que muere un
niño que no puede estudiar un trabajador
que no puede trabajar en la propia corte
suprema declaró como graves las
acusaciones de supuestas ejecuciones
arbitrarias durante la operación desde
la onu se ha mostrado también
preocupación por el uso de la fuerza por
parte de la policía sembramos o
recordamos a las autoridades brasileñas
que el uso de la fuerza debe aplicarse
sólo cuando sea estrictamente necesario
la fuerza letal debe utilizarse como
último recurso y sólo en los casos en
que haya amenaza inminente para la vida
o lesiones graves además afirmaron temer
que la policía pueda ocultar pruebas de
las muertes por lo que han hecho un
llamado a hacer una investigación
independiente
algo no funciona o muchas cosas no
funcionan y creo que probablemente sea
necesaria una revisión colectiva como
hemos sugerido una revisión amplia de lo
que está fallando y cómo solucionar por
disco en ground and thrive excel cabe
recordar que la corte suprema brasileña
suspendió este tipo de acciones
policiales en 2020 después de que los
uniformados mataran a 60
5 personas en las favelas durante el
confinamiento